let me pull up this story because i
simply googled it and i found it from
reason male student accuses female
student of sexual assault says he wanted
she says he wanted revenge title ix
creates a prisoner's dilemma students
have to file sexual misconduct
complaints to avoid being the accused
this is actually really crazy the gist
of the story is that a male accuser
uh in an unusual move filed a title ix
complaint against her the female
students uh filed a lawsuit so this is
an inversion of what we typically see
where the male gets accused i think this
guy just knew what the game was good
he's like she's going to falsely accuse
me let's go for it exactly it's kind of
like what sheamus was saying as well
about how this whole situation is
eroding the male female dynamic right
where there's almost like this you know
race to see who's who's gonna file on
the other person first you know
defensively and this is for people who
just you know made love look at this
look at this it says so there's a was it
jane rowe and john doe because their
names are blocked out so the woman
contends it was ridiculous to find her
guilty of non-consexual sex because of
of the man's drunkness but not find him
guilty too because she was also drunk it
doesn't matter you made this game this
is what see this is this is why young
men are like feminism is bad because
this is what it results in it's like you
go into the bedroom you hook up and then
as soon as you're done you're both
looking at each other looking at the
door and then you're both running full
speed trying to accuse each other of
being the aggressor that's completely
insane yes i don't it's nuts i i don't
maybe i'm taking a different view of
hookup culture i i kind of went through
it in the 90s no well more than 2000
early 2000s late 90s but i never really
found it abhorrent or i had a problem
with it like i would hook up with a girl
and we would both have a great time and
then that would be that and then i would
never really if we would or wouldn't
talk again after that and it was just
really fun you know sex is fun it's like
why do you people snowboard
it's fun it's exercise yeah but
snowboarding doesn't carry the risk with
it of like creating another human life
and i shouldn't even call a risk right
creating a human life is a beautiful
thing but what if he was bringing his
life when you got to the bottom of the
mountain just had a baby
then you know what we would have we
would have some very strong social
stigmas around who you went snowboarding
with probably and how often you
snowboarded in whether you having
whether you were snowboarding outside of
merit i think that's true dad where do
babies come from well son when a men and
women love each other they go
snowboarding by the time they reach the
bottom of the mountain what about the
people who ski that's unnatural
you are right it's not a sport sex is
not a sport and it shouldn't be treated
like that i mean i feel like the path
we're on it will be yeah like you're
going to have weird it's a race to the
court yeah yeah it's bad well right now
it's it's a sprint it's like you're in
college and you hook up you both are
like
well uh uh that was great i'm gonna go
to bed and then you like the guy starts
like speed walking towards the the title
nine office or whatever and then he gets
halfway he like he's like halfway there
and then all of a sudden down the end of
the hallway he sees the woman and they
just both bolt for the door like uh
running towards it that's that's where
this is going you gotta oh sorry no no
you go delineate between sex has the the
pregnancy aspect which is what but also
the orgasm which is like
i mean that's
you get better at it the more you do it
from my experience and the more you
study it so like if someone's like never
will have sex only until they're about
ready to have a baby then they're
missing out on the opportunity to
you know give their partner an orgasm or
50 organizations
disagree
did you know uh you i think i think you
all might know this that women
who uh
abstain from sex until marriage report
greater satisfaction isn't that yeah i'm
pretty sure yes and they're also the
least likely to divorce yeah right it is
true it is true and also i just wanted
to say i know that you said you had a
certain experience in college with sex
that was different from this you know
kind of um race to the courtroom thing
and i wanted to just mention that it was
in 2014 that the obama administration
announced this new effort to combat
sexual assault on campuses and i think
that's really when this whole thing of
like title ix somebody and like you know
young men if they're accused that they
have to be removed immediately like
while this kangaroo court situation
happens so if you were able to graduate
from college before 2014 it might have
been a different world oh yeah it was in
2001 that's when i graduated oh yeah
well you know i've sort of said this
before you know i'm a traditionalist i
wear that on my sleeve but what the left
often does is in the long run after
they've broken down the social
boundaries they try to imitate
traditionalism but in a much more
convoluted way and so what we see is as
it would be the case in the past people
uh do get in trouble for having sexually
immoral encounters but because we don't
know how to label a consensual sexual
encounter as immoral people jump to it
was assault now obviously yes there are
people who are genuinely assaulted and
there should be resources for them but
it just happens to be the case that they
have this entire infrastructure set up
with these kangaroo courts which as
we've described will punish people for a
crime that they did not commit it will
charge them not as someone who's
fornicated but as someone who has raped
it's interesting because also from a
psychology perspective we think about
internal locus of control versus
external locus of control so internal is
where i believe that i'm the one in the
driver's seat in my life i'm the one
choosing if i have those drinks and
sleep with that guy or whatever else and
the external locus of control is you
know oh well it was the situation it was
the patriarchy i was you know whatever
and as if the world is happening to us
like the weather and psychology studies
have shown that people with an internal
locus of control tend to you know be
less vulnerable to things like anxiety
and depression it's a it's a factor of
resilience to feel that you have
self-efficacy and that you are in charge
of your own decisions so i do think that
this whole thing um has not been good
you know for women or for men when we
start seeing that it's not just
you me and the lamp post you know
deciding what we're doing here but that
we think we start blaming all these
social factors instead of just looking
at our own behavior i mean that's that's
the culture war in a nutshell yeah
people being like it's not my fault i
did it it's patriarchy is that like a
result of psychoactives being introduced
to young people that they now have less
of an internal locus of control they're
they're seeing it happening i i think
that there's been this big movement you
know to to to to d shame women right for
if if they want to have sex and you know
whatever they want to do you know girl
power again all of that kind of stuff
and so therefore if a woman does have
regrettable sex
maybe within that framework it wouldn't
really be permissible for her to say you
know i feel shame i don't feel like
that's good for me i don't think i want
to do that again because then she'd have
to look at herself and say that she
wants to do something differently which
would go against the grain of this other
narrative of saying women are just like
men you can go have sex all the time
with a bunch of people and you'll be
fine um and so then because she she
can't blame her you know her own choices
then the only alternative is to start
blaming other people
and there are no strong men
to stand up and say enough i mean there
are but they're all right-wing now i
mean even if they're not right-wing
they're right-wing that's what's
happening that's what they're joe rogan
is a right-wing comedian i suppose
because if because if you have any kind
of masculinity i mean this is probably
why they call joe rogan right wing he's
a meat head
he is a ripped mma dude who goes bow
hunting for elk
he's got left-wing politics but that
doesn't matter he's masculinity yeah you
need a dude that'll stand up and say
enough but also that will cry
in feeling what she is feeling like
jordan peterson so i think he's kind of
the embodiment of the strong man right
now peterson seems to be although he's
not a meat head and i don't know what he
mentions
when we when we had uh we had tyler
fisher on the other night and he said
that he he was raised by two dads he
said that he was very much you know woke
and everything until he started
listening to jordan peterson and jordan
peterson helped him get to get his life
in order and i'm like that's exactly why
they fear jordan peterson so much
teaching teaching young men personal
responsibility teaching young men to be
masculine that's very dangerous for
people who don't want that balance
brought back to the force absolutely and
so i've said this before on the show i
honestly mostly blame men for feminism i
think the reason women are acting like
men is because men are acting like
children and people will usurp the roles
that are not being fulfilled by the
people who are responsible for them in
some sense and so i think we're in a
position where society has basically as
you've mentioned put a lot of emphasis
on areas where we think women might be
falling behind relative to men whenever
men are falling behind that's never
really considered a problem
and so now we have a system where women
are actually able to
um contribute to the economy in the
workforce in a way that a lot of men
can't compete with within the romantic
marketplace and so
a you have that but then b it's far
outside of an economic issue it's also
an issue of virtue like men are not
taught to see women as people who they
should love and protect and care for
think about what porn has done to men's
brains it has convinced them that women
are objects for their own sexual
pleasure and not human beings who they
should love and in commune with and
genuinely care for and protect well to
tie together what you were saying about
women being told they shouldn't feel
ashamed for sleeping with a bunch of men
it makes me
angry to a certain degree that women are
told that they need to behave like men
you need to work you need to fight you
need to do all of this stuff you need to
take action against people who take
advantage of you you don't actually need
to do that and the fact of the matter is
that men and women view sex very
differently i understand that i'm okay
with that i'm not fighting against that
because it's a biological imperative
women connect much more deeply than men
with sex on a very emotional level
because women tend to be more emotional
and that's okay that's fine that's
wonderful it's beautiful men are not the
same even at a neurochemical level like
women release a bunch of oxytocin it's
really it's really crazy because did you
know that the better the sex is the more
orgasms the woman has the more oxytocin
she releases right so the more bonded
she gets to the guy the the better the
sex is for her exactly which is awful
right because like if you go out and
you're going to have that one night
stand well it better be good right
you're not doing it for relationship
fulfillment right it's just a you know
sex and then you end up getting like
really bonded to the person well that
that explains why uh women who are
abstained from sex until marriage tend
to report greater satisfaction
so i read that i'm not gonna i'm not
saying i know for a fact i don't have
the evidence pulled up but i'm you know
that that is the case
and for men the more like orgasms and
the more forceful orgasms that they have
right
fine great and the more testosterone
they get their testosterone rises and
rises which makes them you know just
more and more independent and all these
other things right
it's really hard for women thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you